[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich werde es eine geschichte erzählen
und ich möchte dass du darüber
nachdenkst ob sich dabei um einen echten
fall oder science-fiction handelt
sie spielt sich in einer wichtigen stadt
mehrere 100.000 einwohnern ab in der
stadt die in einer bucht liegt
an einem tagen dichten nebel taucht
plötzlich ein schiff auf und versteckt
sich im schutze dieser dicken suppe
dann beginnt das schiff mit einer
erosion kann ohne etwas seltsames in der
luft zu verteilen
worum nur kann es sich bei diesen
geheimnisvollen aerosol handeln
wie sich später herausstellen sollte um
nichts geringeres als krankheitserreger
bakterien
also was meint ihr ist diese geschichte
echt oder nicht nur was ich dir gerade
beschrieben haben ist nicht der anfang
eines science fiction films oder eines
perversen experiments von doktor mengele
ich erzähle dir etwas das 1950 wirklich
passiert ist und die betroffene stadt
war san francisco keine geringere als
die armee der vereinigten staaten hat
über dieser stachel börsen cisco nicht
nur einmal sondern mindestens sechs mal
die batterien bacillus subtilis und sehr
ratsam als es verbreitet ohne dass die
bevölkerung der stadt auch nur im
geringsten etwas davon wusste gemäss dem
damaligen stand des wissenschaftlichen
konsens galten diese bakterien zwar
nicht als für den menschen schädlich
trotzdem große überraschungen führt
dieses experiment zum tod von mindestens
einer person um mindestens 10 weitere
mussten in krankenhäusern behandelt
werden
denn im falle des bakteriums härtetests
es wurde später bewiesen dass es eben
doch gesundheitsschädlich ist außerdem
führte sein massiver einsatz im rahmen
von experimenten wie diesen dazu dass
sich stämme herausbilden konnten die
extrem resistent gegen antibiotika sind
und bis heute in der regel mit einiger
häufigkeit schwere ausbrüche verursachen
die nur schwer unter kontrolle zu
bekommen sind die größenwahnsinnigen
us-wissenschaftler haben also mit ihren
leichtfertigen experimenten eine
gefährliche solche herangezüchtet die es
vorher nicht gab bravo applaus ganz
großes kino aber an dieser stelle
stellen sich sicher viele von euch meine
frage warum in aller welt haben die
vereinigten staaten beschlossen ihre
eigene bevölkerung mit bakterien zu
infizieren
was wollten sie damit erreichen
nun die erklärung liegt im b
waffenprogramm dass die vereinigten
staaten 1943 ins leben gerufen haben
mindestens 20 jahre lang zwischen 1949
und 969 wurden militärische tests mit
bakterien durchgeführt die für
kriegszwecke verwendet werden sollten
wir sprechen über unverantwortliche
menschenexperimente die in städten
durchgeführt wurden und bei denen die
eigene zivilbevölkerung selbst als
unwissende versuchskaninchen missbraucht
wurde aber mach es bitte kein fehler man
kann dies keineswegs mit jenen
versuchskaninchen vergleichen von denen
olaf scholz sprach der meinte nämlich
wissende versuchskaninchen nicht
unwissende ein himmelweiter unterschied
und glaube nicht eine sekunde daran dass
all diese menschlichen versuchskaninchen
die ersten oder die letzten waren diese
ersten versuchen gibt es schon seit
vielen vielen jahren
ist du also mehr erfahren über die
unbarmherzige welt der biologischen
waffen und die bedrohung die sie
wirklich darstellen könnten glaubst du
dass dir in der heutigen welt auf einen
möglichen biologischen angriff
vorbereitet sind oder dass wir heute ist
solche experimente die forschung und
ihre folgen im griff haben wenn dich
diese fragen interessieren dann passt
jetzt gut auf
[Musik]
die waffen das düsterste kapitel der
militärgeschichte
bevor wir mit dieser geschichte beginnen
kommt eine kleine entwarnung allerdings
die letzte die entwicklung und das
experimentieren mit biologischen waffen
ist seit 1975 durch das übereinkommen
über das verbot der entwicklung
herstellung und lagerung
bakteriologische und biologischer waffen
und von toxin waffen sowie über die
vernichtung solcher waffen verboten
offiziell hat daher die überwiegende
mehrheit der staaten dieser welt
aufgehört sich zu entwickeln und mit
ihnen zu experimentieren
was sie heute also nur im verborgenen
tun können konnte bis 1975 ganz offen
praktiziert werden und es gab gleich
mehrere länder die von dieser freiheit
exzessiven gebrauch machten die waffen
wie am fließband entwickelten und sogar
häufig einsetzen wir sprechen hierbei
hauptsächlich über die usa die
sowjetunion und japan aber sie waren
durchaus keine pioniere schon lange
bevor diese mächte ihre
bakteriologischen entwicklungspläne für
militärische zwecke starteten haben
biologische waffen bereits eine lange
geschichte hinter sich
dort ersten überlieferten einsätzen von
b waffen wissen wir mindestens aus dem
sechzehnten jahrhundert vor christus von
den hethitern es gibt auch belege dafür
dass die skythen im vierten jahrhundert
vor christus mit krankheitserregern
verseucht pfeile auf ihre feinde
abfeuerten und es ist auch bekannt dass
es bei personen griechen und römern
üblich war die brunnen und wasserquellen
ihrer feinde mit toten tieren zu
vergessen ihren ansteckenden krankheiten
gestorben waren eine praxis die sich
quer durch die geschichte sieht etwas
ähnliches haben auch die tataren im 14
jahrhundert massenweise angewendet sie
katapultierten pest infiziert körper auf
die genueser im koffer die briten
verteilten dem achtzehnten jahrhundert
punkten infizierte decken an
amerikanische ureinwohner ebenfalls eine
praxis die bereits die spanier ein paar
hundert jahre zuvor eingeführt haben
aber wir müssen für den massiven einsatz
biologischer waffen gar nicht so weit in
die vergangenheit zurückblicken japan
setzt diese art von waffen in der ersten
hälfte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
ausgiebig 1
das kaiserreich hatte sogar eine eigene
einheit namens 731 welche die
auswirkungen bestimmter bakterien und
viren auf leben der gefangenen
erforschte diese krankheitserreger kamen
dann während der japanischen invasion
züge in ostasien wahllos zum einsatz
so setzte zum beispiel japan im jahr 139
das bakterium salmonella tiefwasser
reservoirs in der damaligen sowjetunion
zu kontaminieren aufgrund dieser
vorfälle und des zunehmenden einsatzes
biologischer waffen riefen auch die usa
143 mitten im zweiten weltkrieg ihr
eigenes programm ins leben ein programm
das die zehnte land aktiv sein sollte
und den amis die fragwürdige ehre
einbrachte die fortschrittlichste macht
in sachen biologischer kriegsführung zu
werden
die frage ist nur zu welchem preis nun
schnell ich liebe an denn wir werden
hier über eine menge sachen sprechen
müssen die einige von euch ziemlich
schocken werden denn wenn die geschichte
aus san francisco die wir die am anfang
des videos erzählt haben schon ein wenig
überraschend für dich war mach dich
lieber auf etwas gefasst was jetzt kommt
wird noch viel viel schlimmer
[Musik]
bürger gleich versuchskaninchen
die sache in san francisco war ganz und
gar kein einzelfall tests mit
biologischen waffen die aus chemischen
waffen fehlten in den usa jahrelang
relativ häufig zur praxis der regierung
welche dabei natürlich immer vorgehabt
nur das beste für ihre bürger eben sinne
zu haben das hauptziel dieser test war
es ein verständnis dafür zu gewinnen wie
sich ein biologischer angriff auf die
bevölkerung auswirken würde
um diese forschung voranzutreiben und
setzte das us militär manchmal der
chemikalie auch bakterien frei die
damals als harmlos oder unschädlich
galten sogenannte ersatzstoffe
[Musik]
dann wurde die luft analysiert um
herauszufinden wie weit und in welcher
konzentration sich die stoffe ausbreiten
leider erfahren sowohl die feldversuche
als auch die wissenschaftlichen fakten
darauf welchen sie basierten nicht immer
sagen wir mal präzise
in den jahren 1957 und 58 setzte die us
armee zum beispiel eine umgebung von
saint louis und in minnesota tief liege
ein die ein gemisch aus casineum und
zingst über städtischen gebieten
versprühten und für diejenigen unter
euch die es nicht wissen cadmium ist
hochgradig giftig und krebserregend nun
die gewissenlosen militärs und
wissenschaftler wussten es und jetzt
haltet euch fest sie führten diese
experimente an einer völlig ahnungslosen
zivilbevölkerung durch vor allem in
vierteln in denen schwarze und sozial
schwache minderheiten wohnten aber das
ist nicht alles ähnliche experimente
fanden bis 1968 in vielen verschiedenen
teilen des landes statt die folgen
kannst du dir vorstellen
[Musik]
ja später wurde in mehrere studien
festgestellt dass in den gebieten in
denen diese experimente durchgeführt
wurden die häufigkeit verschiedene
krebsarten anstieg und das beste oder er
das schrecklichste kommt noch dass die
menschen die seltsamen wolken und den
dunst hinterfragten erklärte die
us-regierung einfach dass die flugzeuge
ein experiment durchführten um die
städte in eine art nebel zu hüllen der
dienst alle eines luftangriffs schützen
sollte
natürlich wurde auch schon damals jeder
rallye version der regierung
hinterfragte als
verschwörungstheoretiker verräter
kommunist des informator und allgemein
verrückter deformiert und ins medial
gesellschaftliche abseits geschoben so
und wenn dir das alles als eine riesige
ungeheuerlichkeit vorkommt die große
ausnahme die es so heute nicht mehr
geben könnte dann warte bis du siehst
was sie 1966 selbst in new york city
gemacht haben
in jenem jahr wurden mehrere experimente
mit dem bakterium bacillus subtilis in
der new yorker u bahn während der
hauptverkehrszeit durchgeführt in diesem
fall bestanden die experimente darin mit
bakterien gefüllte glas kälbchen auf die
gleise in die züge selbst und durch
luftschächte zu werfen um zu sehen wie
weit und wie virulent sich ein echter
biologische angriff ausbreiten könnte
wenn die u-bahn das ziel wäre diese
behälter ersetzten beim zerbrechen
millionen von bakterien in die luft frei
die in vielen fällen die züge gelangten
und kilometerweit durch den untergrund
der stadt transportiert wurden die
studie ergab dass bei einem biologischen
angriff auf den new yorker u-bahn
millionen von menschen der krankheit
ausgesetzt wären und die erreger aus
nach einem angriff einen großteil der
stadt erreichen könnten ja du hast
richtig gehört es mit echten bakterien
in der new yorker u-bahn veranlasst
durch die us regierung überrascht nun im
new yorker rathaus war man genauso
beeindruckt denn anstatt die örtlichen
behörden so warnen er vor die new yorker
regierung erst 1980 geschlagen das 14
jahre später von diesen tests mit
bakterien in ihrer eigenen stadt gut an
dieser stelle bin ich mir sicher dass
zumindest ein paar von euch denken
werden okay das ganze ist schrecklich
und leicht verwerflich aber das war des
kalten kriegs militärs politiker medien
und wissenschaftler hatten ständig panik
vor den russen die im reich des bösen
alle waren ein ständiger hysterie und
angst so was können wir uns doch heute
gar nicht mehr vorstellen nicht wahr in
einer solch emotional aufgeladenen
irrationalen stimmungen greift man halt
schon mal zu rabiaten methoden
schließlich gegen es ja ums große und
ganze und allgemeinwohl nicht wahr haben
all diese schrecklichen übungen also
zumindest die fähigkeit der vereinigten
staaten verbessert mit einem
biologischen angriff umzugehen die
prozente heute darauf vorbereitet würde
ein solcher angriff eine globale
bedrohung darstellen nun lasst uns das
mal richtig ergründen
[Musik]
der reality check
sind die usa vorbereitet 0 nicht
wirklich was glaubst du haben all diese
experimente dafür gesorgt dass amerika
nun vor einem echten biologischen
angriff gefeit ist sie wurden doch von
hochkarätigen experten
wissenschaftlern und strategen
veranlasst und durchgeführt nun falls du
wirklich so naiv sein solltest das zu
glauben liegst du total daneben und das
behaupte nicht nur ich nein das ist das
urteil vieler usb ob der experte das
gefühl ist dass wir nicht vollständig
vorbereitet sind selbst wenn im falle
eines angriffs behandlungsmöglichkeiten
gegenmittel oder einen impfstoff hätten
wir nie gebraucht haben wir nicht die
kapazität 330 millionen amerikaner damit
zu versorgen us regierungsbeamter der
nicht öffentlich genannt werden möchte
aber wie kann es sein dass ein land dass
jedes jahr sechs milliarden dollar in
die biologische verteidigung investiert
nicht auf einen biologischen angriff
vorbereitet ist
[Musik]
um das zu verstehen geben wir dir ein
beispiel die puppen eine tödliche
krankheit die durch das mariola virus
verursacht wird welches in der freien
natur bereits ausgerottet ist aber in
labors vor allem in amerikanischen und
russischen noch in großen mengen
vorgehalten wird
wenn dieses virus plötzlich in einer
stadt freigesetzt würde egal ob es
versehentlich oder absichtlich passiert
wäre es praktisch unmöglich seine
anfängliche ausbreitung zu entdecken und
zu stoppen denn zwischen dem angriff und
dem auftreten der ersten symptome liegt
eine inkubationszeit von mehreren tagen
in der sich das virus in der stadt nach
belieben bewegen würde zum beispiel
hätten vorgestern gerade in deiner stadt
ein bombenanschlag stattgefunden haben
können ohne dass du in diesem moment
irgendeine ahnung davon haben könntest
und wenn du dann endlich merkt dass ein
biologischer angriff stattgefunden hat
könntest du bereits hunderte tausende
von menschen infiziert haben die dem
tode geweiht sind menschen die bis dahin
lässt sich jedoch selbst zu echten
biologischen waffen werden würden sie
selbst würden das virus ungewollt
verbreiten und viele weitere menschen
infizieren auf der anderen seite
verfügen die vereinigten staaten derzeit
über einen realen bestand von etwas mehr
als 15 millionen dosen impfstoff diese
sind praktisch jederzeit einsatzbereit
aber würde dies wirklich vor einem
möglichen biologischen angriff schützen
nun die wahrheit ist dass das alles
andere als klar ist
wer die zeit die man bräuchte um das
virus zu entdecken eine massive ins
kampagne in der betreffenden stadt oder
region zu starten und tatsächlich alle
einwohner zu impfen wäre beträchtlich
während dieser zeit würde sich die zahl
der infektionen natürlich weiter
ausbreiten und auf diese weise würden
sich hunderttausende von menschen durch
den biologischen angriff infizieren
bevor die schutzmaßnahmen greifen
könnten außerdem wäre es in einer
zunehmend vernetzten welt nur eine frage
von tagen bis sich das virus im ganzen
land oder sogar weltweit verbreitet und
natürlich stehen in den gesamten
vereinigten staaten wie gesagt nur etwa
15 millionen impfdosen zur verfügung dh
selbst in dem land mit den größten
reserven der welt könnten kaum mehr als
sieben prozent der bevölkerung geimpft
werden 93 prozent wären ihm hilflos
ausgeliefert aber das ist nicht das
einzige problem denn im kritischen und
entscheidenden zeitfenster nach dem
ausbruch welches nur wenige tage lang
ist wären nur 90.000 dosen für den
sofortigen einsatz verfügbar
nur 90.000 impfdosen wie gesagt das wäre
die situation in den usa auf
internationaler ebene wäre sie
wahrscheinlich noch dramatischer
um die reine vorstellung davon zu geben
es wird geschätzt dass weltweit in den
lagern nur etwas mehr als 60 millionen
weitere dosen lagern stell dir also vor
dass es infolge eines bio angriffs oder
eines unfalls wirklich zu einem
weltweiten ausbruch kommen würde was
aufgrund der inkubationszeit und der
globalen reiseströme das szenario mit
der höchsten eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit
ist wie du siehst können wir bei den
real zur verfügung stehenden
abwehrmaßnahmen wirklich nur von einem
tropfen auf den heißen stein sprechen
und wenn der außerdem berücksichtigen
dass die vernetzung zwischen regionen
und ländern heute die größer ist als zur
zeit der natürlichen ausbrüche dieses
virus bevor es ausgerottet wurde könnte
das ergebnis tatsächlich eine bedrohung
für die menschheit darstellen
just cause 2 würden wir danach locker
unter ferner liefen verbuchen können
aber abgesehen von dieser wirklich
düsteren frage gibt es noch ein anderes
problem das bio sicherheitsexperten
genauso groß oder nicht sogar noch
größere sorgen bereitet ich spreche
davon das ist heutzutage sehr einfach
und billig ist krankheitserreger wie
bakterien und viren genetisch zu
verändern
in den letzten jahren wurden in diesem
bereich dank einer neuen methode des
ging in die tieren des namens christa
kasten dramatische fortschritte erzielt
[Musik]
es handle sich um eine technik mit der
gene viel genauer schneller und auch
billiger bearbeitet werden können als je
zuvor die technik besteht hauptsächlich
darin ein enzym namens cassel zu nutzen
um die dna sequenz an der gewünschten
stelle abzuschneiden und so die
möglichkeit so haben neues genetisches
material in die lücke einzuschließen
material das zu einem völlig anderen
bakterium oder virus gehören kann sodass
merkmale künstlich hinzugefügt oder
entfernt werden können chris backus 9
hat die kosten für diese art genetischer
manipulation auf durchschnittlich 3000
dollar gesenkt um bio waffen zu
schmieden braucht man also keinen
militärhaushalt von hunderten milliarden
dollar und um sie einzusetzen braucht
man kein millionär keine großen drohnen
flotten oder flugzeugträger es braucht
nur ein labor und eine kleine
investition um chaos zu stiften
am ende ist es sogar das beste das ganze
unter dem deckmäntelchen gemeinnütziger
forschung zu verbergen und bevor ich es
vergesse nicht nur die kosten sind
drastisch gesunken auch die
entwicklungszeit mit dieser technik
konnte der ganze prozess von etwa 18
monaten auf etwas mehr als drei wochen
verkürzt werden drei wochen
[Musik]
wir sprechen hier von nichts geringerem
als einer echten revolution auf dem
gebiet der biomedizin eine revolution
mit zunächst ausgesprochen positiven
auswirkungen so hat sich zb die
veränderung von pflanzen genomen
vereinfacht um sie resistent gegen
schädlinge und bakterien zu machen und
so die ernährungssicherheit in viel
verarmten ländern zu gewährleisten die
ständig unser solchen katastrophen
leiden
die gentechnisch veränderten pflanzen
helfen auch den einsatz von pestiziden
und herbiziden zu reduzieren und so die
übrige umwelt zu schonen aber wie jede
große erfindung bringt chris packers 9
neben den vielen seiten als positiven
ansatz möglichkeiten eben auch viele
neue gefahren wenn ein land oder sogar
eine terror-organisation diese methode
heimlich nutzen würde um gentechnisch
veränderte bakterien oder viren zu
erzeugen um sie widerstandsfähiger
tödlicher oder ansteckender zu machen
und sie als biologische waffen
einzusetzen könnte das für die
biosicherheit eine herausforderung von
astronomischen ausmaß sein
mit hilfe moderner gentechnischer
werkzeuge können selbst angehende
virologie doktoranden coronaviren
manipulieren hose dabei im gentechnisch
erzeugten virus spuren dieser
manipulation zu hinterlassen das cisco
roma virus 2 zb verfügt über eine so
genannte ferienspaß stelle dieses virus
infekte und virulenter macht diese ist
bei keinem andere stars corona virus
bekannt wird aber oft im rahmen von gain
auffangschiff studien in der
virusforschung eingebaut als game of
function wird die genetische
manipulation von krankheitserregern
bezeichnet die darauf abzielt ihre
virulenz und tätlichkeit zu erhöhen tja
und jetzt ratet mal wer ebenfalls viele
jahre lang experimente mit stars
ähnlichen fledermaus korrigieren
durchgeführt hat einschließlich der oft
kritisierten game of function forschung
genau unsere freunde von der us-armee
diese forschung wird von der us armee
und anderen regierungsstellen finanziert
unter dem vorwand man müsse aus
sicherheitsgründen gefährlichen
situationen natürlich vorkommende
erreger im labor züchten um gegenmittel
erforschen zu können
es geht dabei jedoch gar nicht so sehr
darum dass ihr einsatzbereite bio waffen
hergestellt werden vielmehr besteht das
hauptrisiko darin dass die viren franken
steigt von heute genauso wenig alle
gefahren und auswirkungen ihrer
handlungen überblicken können wie die
forscher damals in der bucht von san
francisco
fakt ist 2014 wurde die hochriskante
corona virusforschung selbst den us
militärs zu heikel aufgrund von
sicherheitsbedenken stoppten sie ihre
versuche und verlegten sie an einen
anderen ort nämlich nach china als
johanna institut für virologie kurz wfv
als mittelsmann dieser experimente
fungierte dabei eine ngo namens eco
health alliance die von einem doktor
peter dächert geleitet wird nach der
ausrufung der korona pandemie wurden
zwei offizielle gruppen mit der
untersuchung des ursprungs des virus
beauftragt eine baugruppe und eine von
der wissenschaftszeitschrift the lancet
der leiter der lancet kommission wurde
ausgerechnet doktor.de und wer wurde
später führendes mitglied des dhb teams
dreimal darfst du raten genau doktor.de
schaaf machte sich sofort ans wert ohne
dass es auch nur einen ansatz eines
untersuchungsergebnisses gegeben hätte
wurde von führenden wissenschaftlichen
gremien sofort offene briefe
veröffentlicht in denen behauptet wurde
dass ein labor ursprung von just cause 2
extrem unwahrscheinlich oder eine
verschwörungstheorie sei später kam dann
heraus dass all diese briefe hinter den
kulissen von keinem geringeren als
doktor deschacht koordiniert wurden
jenem mann der eigentlich ergebnisoffen
herausfinden sollte ob das virus aus dem
labor kommt oder nicht der größte
geldgeber der eco health alliance ist
übrigens das us-militär unser in der
bucht von san francisco begonnene kreis
scheint sich in bochum zu schließen
bisher ist dies alles nur ein verdacht
denn auch wenn die suche nach einem
tierischen zwischen wird bisher
erfolglos geblieben ist kann und darf
ein natürlicher ursprung für das co2
nicht ausgeschlossen werden gewissheit
darüber könnten die umfassenden
datenbestände des johanna instituts für
psychologie liefern dumm nur dass dieses
eine forschungs datenbank über viren die
von tier zu mensch übertragen werden
just im september 2019 vom netz genommen
hat nur kurz bevor die ersten kurve
patienten in den krankenhäusern wo hans
auftauchten und wenn wir eines aus der
geschichte der biowaffen experimente des
us-militärs gelernt haben ist es doch
genau dieses muster verantwortungslose
experimente werden ohne rücksicht auf
menschliche verluste durchgeführt
vollkommen intransparent unter dem
deckmäntelchen der wohltätigkeit und
gesundheitsfürsorge wenn dann mal ein
verdacht aufkommt etwas könnte schief
gelaufen sein wird alles dementiert
kritiker und zweifler reflexartig
delegitimiert es wird nur genau das
zugegeben was gar nicht mehr zu leugnen
ist und ansonsten alle spuren verwischt
und genau deshalb fragen sich viele von
uns wie engagiert dies noch gut gehen
könnte die welt heute mehr denn je durch
biologische bedrohungen gefährdet sein
welche maßnahmen sollten ergriffen
werden um diese bedrohung zu
kontrollieren was können wir als bürger
also jeder einzelne von uns dafür tun
und was ist eure meinung zu diesem
ganzen thema wie immer sind wir auf all
eure meinungen hochgradig gespannt ich
hoffe also dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat falls ja gibt uns bitte ein
leichtes mit euren freunden und vergesst
nicht das abo mit glöckchen um keines
unserer videos mehr zu verpassen was gut
und bis bald
[Musik]